كما ذكرنا التطورات الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الفلسطينيه حيث اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمه عسكر بمدينه نابلس ودهمت
منزلي شهيدين حسن قطناني احد منفذي عمليه
اطلاق نار في الاغوار وحسام سليم احد قادت
مجموعات عرين الاسود واخذت قياسات
المنزلين تمهيدا لهدمهما لاحقا كما اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال مخيمه نور شمس في مدينه
طولكرم من محاور عده معززه بجرافات عسكريه
واعتقلت عددا من افراد عائلات مطلوبين
للضغط على ابنائهم لتسليم انفسهم
واصيب جنديا اسرائيلي من وحده
بجروح متوسطه اثر تبادلا لاطلاق النار مع
مقاومين فلسطينيين في مخيم نور الشمس
سميره ابو شمالي معنا من نابلس سمير اخر
المعطيات حول هذه الاقتحامات والعمليات
العسكريه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نعم النشاطات العسكريه والعمليات الاقم
عمليات الاقتحام المستمره على مدار الساعه
سواء في ساعات النهار او الليل هي مستمره
من قبل الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الليله
الماضيه شهدت مدينتا نابلس وطولكرم في
حماه من قبل القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
بدات في مدينه نابلس وتحديدا في مخيم عسكر
والجبل الشمالي في شرقي مدينه نابلس حيث
كان هناك دهن لمنزلي الشهيدين حسن قطناني
وهو الشهيد المتهم بتنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار
على عند حاجز الحمره في غور الاردن والذي
ادى ذلك الى مقتل مقتل ثلاثه في مستوطنات
في نيسان ابريل الماضي وايضا الشهيد حسام
سليم الذي هو والقياده في مجموعات عرين
الاسود المتهم ايضا بتخطيط وتنفيذ لعمليه
اطلاق نار ومقتل جنديه اسرائيلي قربه
مستوطنه شافي شمرون في
اكتوبر الماضي غربي مدينتي نابلس القوات
الايطاليه دهمت هاتين المنطقتين وحاصرت
المنزلين وايضا قامت باخذ القياسات داخل
المنزل منزلين وذلك تمهيدا لهدمهما في وقت
لاحق وذلك في اطار السياسه العقاب الجماعي
لعائلات الشهداء وايضا
للضغط على عائلات بعدم ارسال ابنائهم الى
مقاومه الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه بشكل عام في مخيم نور شمس
تحديدا في طولكرم كان هناك اشتباكات مسلحه
عنيفه فقد دارت بين
مقاتلين كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
الزراعه المسلحه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وايضا مقاومين من اذرع الفلسطينيه مسلحه
اخرى قد تصدوا لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
بشكل عنيف جراء اقتحامها لمخيم نور شمس
وقد حصلت بعض المنازل وذلك بهدف اعتقال
مطلوبين من كتيبه جنين وغيرها في اطار هذه
العمليه ولكن كان هناك اشتباكات مسلحه
اسفرت عن اصابه احد الجنود الاسرائيليين
من وحدات وصفت جراحه بالمتوسط حسب مصادر
الطبيه الاسرائيليه وايضا كان هناك تفجير
عبوات ناسفه في داخل هذه العمليه العسكريه
او خلال هذه العمليه العسكريه وايضا كان
هناك عمليات مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه سواء في نابلس او في طول كرم
من قبل المواطنين خرجوا الى التصدي في
مواجهات مدنيه بالرشح بالحجاره وادى ذلك
الى اصابه العشرات من الفلسطينيين
بالاختناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع خلال
استخدام جيش الاحتلال هذه القنابل لقمع
الفلسطينين
وافراغهم من المناطق التي كانت تنشط فيها
في مدينتي نابلس وايضا في طول كرم ايضا
كان هناك في طولكرم اعتقال لثلاثه
فلسطينيين وذلك في محاوله للضغط على
المطلوبين لدى قوات الاحتلال بتسليم
انفسهم وهم من اقرباء هؤلاء المطلوبين لدى
قوات الاحتلال
وقد تم احتجاز وايضا اجراء تحقيقات
ميدانيه لعدد من العائلات والافراد في
داخل مخيم النور شمس في هذا الاطار للضغط
على المطلوبين للتسليم انفسدين القوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه مدينه نابلس مراسلنا
سمير ابو شمالي